vial banque indique exxon s'est jamais
un truc à dire aliot mcdonald's pour la
suite de sa carrière
enfin en tulle et est ce que l'artiste
il est parti voilà que c'est pas parce
que tu es drôle type mes enfants je leur
les doigts mais j'en ai marre quoi
depuis juillet on m'appelle chocolat
chaud je fais pas çi azimi
[Applaudissements]
un film qui traite d'un sujet important
les clichés et les femmes dans le sport
c'est décevant je fais du sport
oui mais on ignorait minton va pas en
faire maintenant
[Rires]
battu par murray en cause c'est la tombe
et minton permet c'est madame vous êtes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d ahmed est monté à une question et
ahmed bien le coup quand il est là en ce
moment ils en tournage avec les
réalisateurs on embrasse aussi olivier
nakache et eric toledano qui avait fait
bien sûr intouchable et vous êtes en
tournage en ce moment de quoi va pas
tarder à bercy ce faire vous dire tout
de suite c'est un pote a donc si vous
voyez comme par le doit beaucoup dans le
film contrairement à la réalité
j'ai pas composé beaucoup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
géraldine a raison c'est que c'est très
difficile de jouer un abruti bah oui
kingson c'est un des atouts et kadir
aliot mcdo n'est pas là pour la suite de
sa carrière
enfin on tue les voulait qu'on regarde
un petit extrait de son spectacle
ah oui et bien on en a parlé mais la
situation
c'est notre dernière pour c'est notre
dernière promo donc j'espère que ça nous
portera chance mais c'est sûr et et
vraiment je voulais rendre hommage à
alban puisque vraiment dans le film il
est extraordinaire aux roues et 2 vous
êtes et il a une douceur et un truc qui
perd tout sens dans le regard ce qui
fait que toutes ces conneries des
banlieues qui france malgré tout est
vraiment sympa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous